hi
I've always loved the Nathan's hot dog
eating contest as a kid I always used to
wake up early on the 4th of July to
watch seemingly normal human beings
devour 40 50 60 hotdogs I was transfixed
it's such a simple thing to see how many
hot dogs you can eat and it's so
American and it's something that I've
always wanted to try so I just found out
I'm gonna be in the Nathan's qualifier
for the hot dog eating competition on
the surface I have no place in this
competition and I just want to see if I
can put up a respectable number 10 hot
dogs in ten minutes
Nathan's is not paying me for this I
just want to do this this is where
champions are made I'm relatively
confident in my goals I can't really
train train like these competitive
eaters that like stretch their stomach
it just doesn't seem healthy at all
especially for a novice so I'm just
going to eat hot dogs at every
opportunity
Cheers
what if I would normally order one hot
dog I'd order three or four now my
casual trip to supermarket buying enough
hot dogs for a family of ten
I might have to pick up my prayers I'm
up to four hot dogs I'm meeting them
pretty fast spent a lot of the workday
in the bathroom all right what I'm
starting to think about is forgot the
buns the buns it's a lot of bread what
the top competitors do they'll take the
buns and they'll soak it in water and
they just eat it it looks really simple
yeah this is the shooting foam I did the
dipping of the bun in the water for the
first time and it was easily one of the
most disgusting things that's ever hit
my palate Oh every part every inch of my
body was revolting against the entire
idea uh it's gonna be a problem the
whole bunsen really has me pretty down
my friends coming now my dad's gonna be
there I really need something to pick up
my spirit
so I decided I'm gonna go to Coney
Island go to the first Nathan's go where
it were the champions II I remembered
what was like again to enjoy the hot dog
before all this and it was great I think
I'm ready
yeah that's nice shirt
medium or are they a medium is probably
fine I'm the only person I think brought
a cheering section the boys on
over-under at 7 a.m. I think they're out
supporting me have waiting to see if I
throw up Matthew right here buddy you
know what I'm gonna put you right here
Sam
I'm about to vomit
I feel the gag reflex to the seventh hot
dog two and a half minutes left and
there's no way I'm going to get the ten
my friends set the over-under at seven
and a half hot dogs all I have in my
mind now is getting to eight there's 30
seconds left the only way I might get
the over/under as if I soaked the bun
harder than I've ever soaked a bun
before I just dip it fully in that like
32 ounce cup and I just try to shove it
as far in my mouth physic and stop
eating which in your mouth counts and I
got it down lost and he lost badly
Matthew that stomach keep us with me
and I feel like garbage feel pretty bad
I'm happy I did it but it's not
something that I want to do again I
could not respect competitive eaters
more than after this whole experience
you say to yourself I can do exactly
what they can do you can't you just
can't it's not possible
you can't do it I learned firsthand